welcome to this video this is just a
test video for the board design because
today I uploaded a new can of bought
designed with coordinates and it was a
bit of controversial discussion people
some like that some dislike that but it
was pretty clear that in general the the
type of border that a had was was not
liked very much which I understand and
basically agree with but I tried hard to
make it better but that didn't manage to
be honest because the predefined options
he and the software were very very
little and so I didn't know what to do a
tow it around a bit with the files and
with the underlying yeah let's say the
type of the tried to change the files
and any files and whatever and didn't
help but then I reached out to someone
on chess calm the user there who had
post something about both designs before
and he was very friendly and then and
very nice to me and helped me and sent
me a new board designed with new borders
and IM must say I'd like this and I mean
tend to use this design I just wanted to
post this video to to to present this to
you and I will play a couple of games
also to get suggest content into this
but the thing is I'd like to hear your
feedback but I ever say I like it I want
to have the coordinates in because it
simply helps people to to understand the
videos better and if it is no big
obstruction I think it it should be
should be in them and I think with this
kind of design it's it's really fine it
does not really stand out much it's not
this wooden frame which was distracting
the like the the front here which does
not have any fancy effects and in
general this kind of blue border fits
within the general blue
himself I like that please note that in
the next couple of days there still will
be videos posted with the wooden frame
it's not it's just that I made a couple
of videos with this frame that now will
be posted they have been rescheduled for
the next couple of days but after that
it will probably switch to that design
unless people really hate it but I don't
expect that to happen so what I'm going
to do for changes play a couple of
bullet games and let's see what I can do
in one minute the one minute some auto
pairing and I'll starting this now need
to get adjusted to this time controller
as always tricky okay we got a French
defence and I've got slight problems
with my king side other than that I'm
fine jack okay so he's far higher rated
than I am I have fire-rated than he is
I'm sorry so on it seems he was okay
with the draw even though the position
was certainly certainly not very dry I
have this trick with the black rank I
have seven our king g 7 that was lucky I
didn't didn't plan that no I need to get
the King involved let's see what this
end game is over that sound that's not
good oh that's not good I couldn't I
couldn't really avoid material loss here
but at least the night is slightly
awkward yet no I need to trade that's
good now let's say if I trade I'm lost
their so I don't trade but like not not
nice at all and I'm 95 maybe I can get
some sliced some some trick in here I
know I hoped you would take on v six or
seven okay as I can resign back okay
didn't play any warm-up games with that
which is some OS tricky I'm not really
hopeless in one minute is just like I
don't play it often and I need some
games usually two to get into into this
this kind of mode ok I'll they've gotta
Kings Indian pancetta type of position
certainly am a bit better for white but
yeah we're talking about a bullet game
here do you want to take because of
those discovered discovered moves okay
I'm trying to keep a tidy type of
position not too many complications of
faith and fifth possible and now f5 is
very very weak Jack this looks quite
nice i would i would say let's let's
hope this is really a check made almost
okay I'll take I take the piece want to
open the position ready now I'm also up
on time which is very very helpful check
check okay check check it's to look the
tricky here check check check black yeah
it wasn't too great but I need to get
into stride again me start again the
same guy yeah that's that's I didn't
want to play the French again like the
first one this was mostly an accident I
was intending to play chatelet 1e5 jack
yeah that's a theoretical line which I
don't know really and something like
that is right even but okay very tricky
to play with the little time it's
probably originally okay for black but
and yeah it's hard to keep keep all the
all the pawns here not good not good at
all oh that's the full exchange down
James I thought I have I have a pawn but
I don't have any himself that's really
totally totally lost
yeah when I went to the endgame I i
thought i had a pawn really I just
basically miscounted jae-yong takes me
six no okay I can resign that black
resign okay let's let's hope for some
other opponent just for a change
oh come on usually in the one minute
Paul you get opponents really quickly
it's well I play that very very rarely
but once in a while I just i get i get
to get into again sorry oh that's
that'sthat's eduardo main the winner of
the dubai open if i'm not mistaken a
very strong GM he's 2700 player now but
then bullet it seems he just swings okay
walk that that's not easy to play in
bullet jack not at all i have 3 m3 a
special g3 em i have this counter play
with Queenie five it's very tricky to to
play this in bullet chess completely
wacky position Jack Jack one p500 almost
a check jet check check check mate
there's the mate well what I right I
need to check this is remain right yeah
yeah well you just wanted to buy open
with the fantastic score so very strong
player okay well this is just bullet
chest it's not nothing related to 22
serious chest but a funny game f takes
d4 checkmate yeah the first probably
lost at some point okay I'm so let's see
i am here also from from an AGM from
France
I got a mainline Kings Indian fianchetto
oh that's not great probably all the way
back very tough to do any sort of
meaningful incumbent trip in a bullet
game I really don't know how this is
possible even to do something here that
that makes at least a bit of sense KF
five looks very weakening but I don't
want to stay passive all the time okay
for Bishop a 94 yes I know it looks like
dreadful okay they can just take it if
this was quite stupid I mean the
position is bad in any case but this
didn't help him try to somehow okay it
wasn't necessary the sacrifice that he
played no he's opening up the FL for me
that's very serious gown to play to put
it mildly rook g3 only yes he's got two
checks ok go here go here he does not
have a check now I think I can go here
now and queen age three check made white
forfeits due to disconnection oh ok that
wasn't wasn't exactly great for black
what I played that like this it's just
like wow
okay but one minute just what can you do
just need to fight also in this crappy
positions all right so this is a kind of
German fry a french national team match
or something get French players again
starting molecule also high rated I am
hi bishop a shreya that kind of guy ok
you is do this exactly once next time
I'll take it ok this was the blonde I'm
a sacrifice this form queenside play ok
this this kind of stuff was the idea I
have some some nice open lines on the
queenside MMF or not really no I need to
get the night near the attack ok I don't
want to just win a porn or something I
want to smash through here and try to to
go from 8-9 p 67 black forfeit due to
disconnection again why that's weird
yeah it's not like a rage quit or
something it's just like maybe a an
unsteady connection and this is also
isn't lost ya nope it isn't hmm ok so
next game it's not so bad here I have a
plus score something I mean it's not
what did i do and when it upside is the
next game even
this guy is playing very quickly and not
very very good this kind of stuff is
always funny to get Jack let's give this
check I can also check here how to win
no actually it looks like there should
be at the window jak nie def 796 I don't
see the win Jack might have seven here
maybe I don't see it I don't see it
really can I this was a bad news I that
was a bad move and this I didn't see I
know it takes on f7 ah ah no oh no what
ah how could I do that I mean after this
check unbelievable ah come on white
resign I didn't find a win here and then
wow it's a just very little time summer
I don't have examined here and it's just
just quickly I just want to check then
sorry I know it's bullet and everything
but and I'd like to quickly check how I
could have won this because this is
quite quite remarkable and he just
allowed this Jack simple trick and then
I didn't find a win here
here night f seven wins okay night f 7
11 cm yeah there must there must be a
win but I couldn't I didn't see at him
and hear what is the winner this is the
wind ok I understand him there's just
yet dropping as well ok and what I did
is he not winning yet this is not
winning and that's hard to believe but
the computer is only giving this is a
draw amazing Jack Jack yeah and by now i
was i was totally confused and and went
for went for this and this is not really
good yeah ok this is still winning 96
year wins yeah even overlook that if
several say ah ok so next game game
starting Grandmaster hellcat don't know
who that is ah come on that's not a
great opening for white I should have
done for the critical line
yeah not much happening it's pretty
symmetrical jack yeah and no we Scott
bishop t1 check oh hmm too bad okay why
reason we used to try a thing here it's
no no name in there yeah in the one
minute pool you have entirely different
players of course that that you don't
turn it in five minutes Jack you have of
course also players who play all times
all time limits but there will be those
bullet specialists maybe five we're not
too bright all right okay it's playable
ok I'm going to try to block this h5
idea from the get-go try to get
something on the queenside myself
come on oh I took [ __ ] with check this
is the problem check check and no back
check check check check luck who this
guy was pretty quick position wasn't
probably so bad for me but yeah of
course I am i blundered this year
somewhere around here and it shouldn't
be too bad with me coming in here but
maybe i'm not sure what I should do here
and now Carol analyzing a bullet game is
a bit much I'm still always interested
what was going on but who came hard to
play a really good moves with no time on
the clock but here I was I was ahead but
he was just play much quicker ahead on
time I mean position is I know equal
probably
gain started okay Oh against me it's
funny funny opposition here in one
minute chess whoa how should I ever and
be able to recall that the theory here
okay now this is ok as I can play
without so much knowledge therefore
there's always this which should be okay
for me no we remove no I came no I can I
can play a couple of moves maybe here is
somewhat irritated and then bullet time
control right it's not really i thought
i would trap the night which is of
course nonsense you can just take it
maybe the pawns can can do something but
it seems very unlikely check check check
check check check it's still winning
fortunately check check okay it's bullet
I can play on time and bullet right
check check check check check and I'm 90
hundreds of a second okay add the shifty
forward what is sick pre-move know oh
yeah that that was terrible Bishop
deform yeah that's not a very great
position here okay but this this is at
least playable it's not particularly
great but it's um it's okay I'm a decent
bloke hm Bishop a five maybe before 93
yeah something like that but not sure
how bad it really is I can also take on
a five it's maybe not so bad actually
now I get a good knight on d4
and this double point is not the end of
the world
i blundered this wanted to secure the
back rank Jack a five now a threat okay
let's I get to get in down ah that's
unfortunate that III was hanging now f5
f5 is still a threat here this shabbos
is strapped almost back check check
white forfeits on who I was so long time
I didn't even see that oh yeah ah ok
game started again again mr. Smith let's
see
yeah an English Defence pretty m
standard line but why does certainly
somewhat better here not not quite sure
about the exact theory here this is this
is certainly bit of the wider position
okay Bishop d7 there's d5 I want to play
with this d5 unknown I can just take it
of course ah and I rookie 694 was nice
but that's not so nice okay roop tags
can take on f2 at the end but it's not
help right ah ok now that was bad just
bad play resins d5 double christian mark
yeah yeah i was thinking rookie 694 but
he can just take the five of course do i
need to play some some other mousse ok
game started again now they get all this
in the same opponents all the time ok
let's see what i can do here
okay f5 coming now that's not very nice
don't like this position at all may okay
maybe maybe him okay maybe it's playable
it's not not great but also not terrible
dear for this is chick here maybe maybe
take first 27 seconds
takes rookie seven should be nice check
check who gets double check me laughs
it's fine oh I got one in at least I've
just a messy game no idea what was going
on there I was certainly worse somewhere
here I'm some certainly worse maybe not
seriously worse but it's not not very
comfortable my computer likes white
actually for whatever that is Luis okay
so when I was just doing this to test
the the audio a bit either the audio the
the bottom design star so I'll get get
one or two games and now and then call
it the day for this test and i forgot to
prevent me five
yeah that's a nice position I mean a
very typical position for the
symmetrical English slightly slightly
more comfortable for wide at least
enough in a normal chest in bullitt you
always have this tricky vector with the
night okay yeah i just won the pawn for
no particular compensation okay yeah I
can you can go to to c5 but it's still
it's still just a pawn
check check check check black resign
yeah that was the first this just wasn't
a good position I believe I mean he
after he exchanged wins I think okay you
have this blockading ideas but it should
be still very good for white around here
can defend this better like II five for
instance but ok it's nothing more that I
can do I can just do what I can just
play what I played and hope for the best
and this way the capture wasn't good but
ok it's bullet Jess let's see her again
how cat now I'm taking that callous
looks it looks really funky ok just
trying to make it confusing this wasn't
great this before idea
hmm yeah that's quite some pressure on
the b5 night to total messy that totally
messy this position a 6 is hanging if he
takes on e4 okay Wow take here no
now that looks very shaky check oops
check check black Wow it was so
confusing what the heck yeah buh blick
was suddenly I was certainly totally
winning but around here what what did
what the hell I mean okay blundered the
rook after that I should probably win
this somehow it and I was to was to
confuse them especially Bishop b5 I was
just it was just completely mindless
game maybe one game of a 4-2 to end the
session j j1 a couple of tempe here that
looks quite quite nice for white got
very good development got the green
protected unfortunately so there is no
discovered discovered check okay
okay can take f7 next yeah yeah yeah
those little tricks check check I've
rupee a check made checkmate yeah I
cannot get any counter play really
become too looks on the seventh okay
I'll play one again that's that's the
beauty of bullet you if you're so
tempted to just do yet another game and
then you find yourself having played
like two hours for no particular reason
okay I need to get some sort of counter
play here a good pose on e4 maybe f5 f5
just putting on that's nice getting the
shot for Bishop traders is always nice
him now night to e4 yes it's very cute
kf2 two nights d5 and if for I am that's
very nice getting the King to d7 and
then exchange the rooks that's the idea
to add the end win the d6 porn check
this could work
trade now check in to d6 I to be seven
and then take 36 that's the big idea
yeah and now I've got everything located
and so we're now just get to the king
into the game quite an easy win I to c5
next picks up another porno resign yeah
that was quite nice ok one again just
one more maybe I get to fall back sorry
it's not really important but always
this kind of little rating goals ok and
get in pure bullet mochi ok yeah well
that's not full compensation but yeah
it's in this time controls sometimes you
get something like here see for now
sudden chance so suddenly I'm rising the
one might be form so prepare c4 I can
always take 6 as well
c5 is quite strong there's on edge to
this get another bishop are the Queen
straight wow what a disaster I know this
multiple discovered checks threatened
Jang let's do that Jack now just take it
black look up and totally safe okay II
just just one more me maybe I really
managed to get my rating back yeah looks
like a decent structure with relatively
active pieces okay take down just take
take the take the pawns here you will
always have enough play I mean I'm not
I'm not better that's good to have some
material for your structural problems or
then oh that's nice that's nice is that
somewhat of loose position here check
okay we are home it's not bad but c6 is
really weak and this is not ideal maybe
I can make and get the Queen to c3 and
this this could be an idea to play for
win that was it was a good move okay the
only chance that i have is on f2 maybe
but he's got also Queen Queen f form I
office I was too slow simply to slow him
and now we can take you six even okay
check check
hmm that's it's really not working
time-wise black oh no it was really bad
really bad far too slow and export the
script position sorry okay mmm come on
okay so now let's grab the center he
lost lots of time with this straight
traits is wrong with the night h5
business and i want i will open up the
position okay let's let's open up him
check
j/k defended well I mean yeah and the
start this was totally totally bad for
black and now it's okay again
check hmm now ok the letter that he
played really nicely especially
considering that the time control oh I
mean yeah ok now that was strong why
resign I mean around here around here
black is black is just just I have
strategically almost almost losing and
he played this very nicely I need to
play this this totally totally different
lame naughty for like age 492 yeah like
that age form 92 therefore I don't have
examined mode some reason and I know
okay um okay just one more game today
one more game I don't know why this auto
examined the scene starting it not on I
need to need to check that
oh well good move night you wanna add
those letters moves are strong at least
I got something going on the queenside
that's not not bad really I think Lisa
answer of course very tricky position
now look at we can take unfortunately
strong is just playing very strong and
I'm totally down on time yeah yeah just
you're just playing very strong like
what can I do it's a very tricky to play
in this complicated positions that are
totally just technical I mean it's just
playing various very quick moves and not
obviously bad ones and I spend too much
time to to to play that alright so I'll
guess I'll wrap it up at this point it
was only meant to to test the the board
layout so just yeah leave feedback about
that like to know your opinion about
them about the layout you like it and
I'm very positive and then using that um
okay thanks for watching